le barbe il véritable institution de la
région de bo flou on y sent pas de
frénésie pour le super bowl cette année
et pas seulement parce que les ennemis
jurés et détesté les patriotes seront de
la partie oui à mener à son aise
respecte plusieurs joueurs ne respectent
pas notre hymne national explique cet
artisan et j moins d'intérêt mouvement
amorcé l'an passé des centaines de
joueurs majoritairement noirs se sont
agenouillés pendant l'hymne national
pour dénoncer le racisme aux états unis
le président trempe les a insultés et la
controverse a monopolisé l'attention
pendant plusieurs semaines l'aîné fait
n'était tout simplement pas préparés à
la réaction négative des partisans selon
ce journaliste
les côtes d'écouté ont d'ailleurs reculé
de près de 10% cette saison après une
chute de 8% la saison précédente
blessures à des joueurs vedettes durée
trop longue des parties plusieurs
facteurs expliquent ces baisses
mais les racines des maux qui affligent
la nfl sont profondes selon ce
journaliste
il faut remonter au scandale sur les
commotions cérébrales que la ligue a
voulu étouffer kid du sport est moins de
jeunes américains jouent au football car
leurs parents craignent maintenant pour
leur santé
mais parler de la chute de l'empiré fel
serait exagéré la ligue vient de signer
un contrat de plus de 3 milliards de
dollars pour la télédiffusion de ces
parties du jeudi soir
et puis la nfl demeure le meilleur
spectacle capable de faire vivre les
émotions les plus fortes
parlez-en aux joueurs et partisans de
beauf loups qui ont accédé aux séries
éliminatoires pour la première fois en
18 ans sifflé club la radio canada au
feu